I have decided to go all out and  recreate the cake from Kiki's Delivery  Service I actually followed a tasty  recipe that's called the best chocolate  cake which I thought was pretty  appropriate it does involve some pretty  interesting ingredients like mayo and  stout but I made sure to use the best  chocolate I could find and what I ended  up with was this super rich super  chocolatey cake that wasn't too sweet  and it's just very very dense after that  I made my chocolate ganache frosting and  then I just poured that all over my cake  earlier today and oh my God it looked so  good already I was so tempted to eat it  then but of course I couldn't forget  about the decorations which I decided to  make using fondant  put my ribbon back in my tree all right  and then my letters  last one  you want my cake looks like